in this Serene setting this is a high
point for China's diplomatic efforts in
Central Asia
the presidents of Kazakhstan Kyrgyzstan
Tajikistan Turkmenistan and Uzbekistan
gathered in Xi'an at the invitation of
President Xi Jinping
let us work closely together to pursue
common development common affluence and
a common prosperity and embrace a
brighter future for our six countries
president XI said they will encourage
chinese-funded businesses in the region
creating jobs and development
he also committed to an initial 3.8
billion dollars in financing support and
grants throughout the summit president
XI has stressed the stability and
strength of the relationship between
China and each of the Central Asian
countries using phrases like good
neighborliness and enduring friendship
and portraying Beijing as a reliable and
respectful partner for the region
China's presence is growing in the
resource-rich region long considered
moscow's domain of influence with trade
reaching record highs and major
construction projects but experts say
China is not looking to compete with
Russia but rather consolidate its
relationships with friendly countries as
tensions with the U.S grow and for this
entire time both Moscow and Beijing
actually have goals that are very
similar to each other which is not to
have the region democratized not to have
the region uh engage more with the West
this Summit takes place at the same time
as leaders of the G7 meet in Japan
China's growing influence will be one of
the main topics of discussion there with
the U.S accusing Beijing of what it
calls coercive diplomacy
meanwhile chinese-stayed media have
framed the Xi'an Summit as a rebuttal to
those criticisms presenting it as a
forum that unlike the G7 recognizes the
needs of developing countries the
Rivalry between an existing major power
and a rising major power is in a way
natural
but the important thing here is that the
Strategic relationship between the
countries needs to be under management
and under control
the leaders here have committed to
meeting every
with rotating hosting rights and also
establishing a permanent Regional
Secretariat based in China president XI
likened the group to a ship braving the
wind and waves together in a time of
what he called profound change Jessica
Washington altazira Xi'an China
the foreign Ministers of Armenian
Azerbaijan